SPEAKER 1: Huh, That's
a little bit better.
Oh, hey.
I'm here to talk about
important changes
to notifications
in Android Oreo.
Up until now, there hasn't
been a unified way for users
to have fine-grained control
over their notifications
for a single app.
If you have different
types of notifications,
there might be some the
user cares a lot about,
and others that they are less
than thrilled to receive.
Unless you've made custom
preferences for your user,
the default user choice if they
don't want some notifications
is--
do I just want to turn off all
the notifications for this app,
or do I just deal?
Having the user shut
off all notifications
is no good for you, and
it's no good for the user,
if they miss an
important update.
Shoot. where's my demo phone?
O also introduces
notification badges
and other snazzy updates.
But first, let's look at O's
new notification channels.
Notification channels give
fine-grained notification
control with a consistent
settings UI to users.
Here I am on my own device.
I've just got a new notification
about a friend following me,
[? Nyi. ?] I can
long press, and I
see that I have the option to
turn off the follower's channel
or take a look at
all of the channels.
Notification channels,
which are also
called notification
categories in the UI,
are collections of
associated notifications.
Every notification
in O needs a channel,
or it won't even show up.
For my new social local
app, I have two channels,
one for all of the notifications
about follower updates,
and another for direct messages.
You'll want to separate
out your different types
of notifications into
different channels.
You can further organize
notification channels
into channel groups.
Channel groups let you group
notification channels together
in the UI.
For example, you can
have a channel group
for your work
account notifications
and for your personal
account notifications.
To set up a channel,
you simply create
a notification channel
object with a unique string
to identify it.
You can add the default
settings for that channel
and submit the channel.
If you want to add a channel
group, you can make the group
and then add it to your channel.
Submitting a channel
is much like giving it
as a gift to the user.
Once you've submitted
the channels,
the user now owns them
and has full control
over their
notification settings.
As a developer,
you can no longer
modify the settings
of that channel.
You can see what settings
the user has chosen,
and you can make
suggestions, but they
have the ultimate control.
Making channels is
important, because when
you make a notification,
you pass in the channel ID.
In fact, you must
pass in the ID,
or your notification won't
show up on O devices,
and you'll get an error.
In addition to
notification channels,
Android Oreo introduces
notification badges, also known
as dots.
The default behavior
for launchers
that support badges is this--
when there are outstanding
notifications for an app,
I see this little circle
on my launcher icon.
I can then long
press to see a count
of all of the outstanding
notifications and swipe
through them.
This new feature comes for
free for devices running O.
If you need more
control over when
to show badges to your
user or to control
the number of outstanding
notifications,
there are options for you.
So check out the docs.
Finally, O offers a few
other cool notable features.
You can set the background color
for your forgone notifications
using the new
setColorized() method.
You should only use this
for ongoing notifications
that are of the utmost
importance for the user
to notice at a glance, like
a notification I'm actively
using for directions.
Some O devices now
support lock screen
ordering using the category,
priority, and associated
people for the notification.
And the MessagingStyle
style now displays more
content in its collapsed form.
There's also a
addHistoricMessage method
that lets you show a
little bit more context
for the conversation.
We have a sample, code
lab, and documentation
to get you started.
So take a look.
[MUSIC PLAYING]